Speaker 1: There is apparently no low to low
for Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson,
who is now issuing a delusional defense of
George Anthony. Tara Devil there Santos,
you might know him as just George Santos, the
lying Republican congressman who lied about
everything. Tucker Carlson has found a way to
defend him. We are going to look at a clip.
This is really a clinic and disinformation. And
Tucker Carlson starts by talking about Joe Biden,
but it morphs into a defensive defense of George
Santos. And it is fascinating to see. See if you
can pick out the rhetorical tools that Tucker
uses here. I'm going to try to keep a list
of them and then we will discuss.
Speaker 2: So we haven't watched
a ton of cable news recently, but we assume with
mass layoffs underway across the US.
Speaker 1: By the way, this we think,
is funny. You're talking about yourself, Tucker.
Speaker 2: On an egg shortage, crumbling cities,
the prospect of a third world war looming on
the horizon. Right. We should. We knew what
the other channels would be covering because
there are an awful lot of threats out there.
What we didn't know until we tuned into MSNBC and
CNN the other day was that all of those threats go
by a single name, and that name is Mr. George
Santos. George Santos, weeks into his new job
as a freshman member of Congress and just months
from his previous life of near-total anonymity.
Right. Jorge Santos has somehow transformed
in the single most dangerous and historically
significant figure on the global stage today.
Speaker 1: So we have here already two tools
that are used. We have what about ism? And we
have. You could call it reductio ad absurdum.
You could call it straw Manning. So so the
whataboutism is Tucker Carlson shifting from
a discussion about Biden to one about how George
Santos has been treated, which are actually two
completely different things, no matter what
Tucker tries to tell you. And then the sort
of straw Manning is the idea that Democrats are
telling you Santos is the most dangerous guy in
the world. Democrats aren't telling you Sanders
is the most dangerous guy in the world. They're
saying he's laughably dishonest and has no place
in the House of Representatives, which is true.
Speaker 2: Jorge Santos is like 911 in human
form. Nothing will ever be the same. Now that
George Santos is here, you will never forget
the moment you first saw George Santos. Where
were you when George Santos was elected? It's a
story you will tell your grandchildren. Watch.
On Capitol Hill. This is George
Santos's reality. It seems almost every.
Speaker 1: Day there are new.
Speaker 2: Questions about
the freshman congressman's.
Speaker 1: Past, some stretching
back more than a decade.
Speaker 2: Can you keep up.
Speaker 3: With all the Santos allies and
controversies? He is now out trumping Trump
in terms of flooding the zone with excrement.
Speaker 4: Not just saying that he played
volleyball, but he had a scholarship
that he slayed teams from Harvard and.
Speaker 2: Yale.
Speaker 3: A perfect portrayal of self-loathing
that he clearly is so disgusted with himself and
so disgusted with the life that he's led. A life
of lies, a life and fables. People didn't decide
because they thought he was somebody totally,
totally different. It was a lie and a
fraudulent election. He has to rebut.
Speaker 5: Not a volleyball champion. And he
doesn't appear to be a champion of the people
either. The voters did not elect you, Mr. Santos.
They elected a version of you invented by your
imagination. Sadly, George Santos represents
so much that is wrong. Today lies, denial
and the death of shame.
Speaker 2: It was a stolen
election. It was a stolen election. You heard Adam
Kinzinger say it. And CNN filled in the blanks.
Speaker 1: There's false equivalency, which is
also another rhetorical tool, which is that the
left is saying Santos stole an election in the
same way that Trump is saying that Biden stole an
election. And, of course, the two things could not
be more different. So there's false equivalency.
This is really a clinic in logical fallacies.
Speaker 2: It's not just the George Santos claim
that he once played volleyball in court, played
volleyball in college. It's worse than that,
indescribably worse, George Santos told other
people outlet. And CNN can exclusively confirm
this. That he had a volleyball scholarship.
Speaker 1: All right, you get the point. We're
not going to do the full four and a half minutes
of this. Tucker Carlson has found a way to come to
George Santos's defense as someone who is just now
a target of the latest woke mob. I saw a really
good comment on Reddit about this and what that
comment said was. Hopefully 100 years from now, if
the US survives the next hundred years, this sort
of stuff, this era will be seen as the golden age
of ignorance. And school kids will hear about the
things that were said and believed. The military
is really in control right now. Obama's in
control. George Santos is actually a fine person
to be a member of the House of Above all this
stuff. Kids will look back at 2023 and they will
say, How did humans believe that stuff back then?
It will be sort of like when we say, how did they
think at one point that leeches cured all sorts
of different medical conditions? We say, that's
so silly. How could anybody think that? Hopefully
in the future people will learn about this era and
they will say, Wow, what a stupid era. Really, the
golden age of of of ignorance there. And this is
really a good test for how far will they go? Is
there nothing they won't defend if it has an R
next to its name and if the left doesn't like it.
We saw they went for Trump. Now, even with George
Santos, they're finding a way to defend him. It
is of how far will this go sort of situation. And
sadly, I don't think we want to know the answer
because they will go very, very far. We will have
all of these clips that I played for you on both
our Instagram and YouTube accounts. Find us on
Instagram at David Pakman Show. Find us on YouTube
at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show.